hello and welcome to this video playing
SG 17 okay yeah this is the line that I
don't quite
leave in Freud's okay
very
very generous in giving me material okay
so there is the same position with a
knight on c6 where you can take on e4
can I take on e4 here rook e1
d5 takes takes this is certainly verse a
verse version so let's be a conservative
I know that after 94 castles I'm fine
something that analyzed in my Quran I
record one much as a bill I just wanted
to check in if you I mean I really am
NOT a huge fan of grabbing pawns and
then suffer but if you offer me a cent
upon I will be quite interested in
looking at this okay the center part is
too important to not check if you can
take it I think I had this on the board
only very recently and came to the
conclusion in that game that white
should probably retreat to f1 it's more
circumspect Bishop III is not as
convincing the bishop is just not so
well placed there should help to cover
the king a little bit but what is taking
quite a bit of time here
[Music]
just think it's interesting
it's not it not
not a very conventional position but
still surprised that he takes that long
Bishop f1 looks very natural to me
honesty
you know and he's going for it
it's not going to take but it's it's a
useful pre move okay 96 I don't want to
invest too much time and this is
interesting now how do we play this and
I would like to play Knight to h5 and
it's something that I can maybe do if I
play Bishop g4 first
marriage fives actually
sting but okay taking that you three
Queen f6 it's not so it probably does
not work but it is not far away from
working okay so do we play this now I'm
going to do it and just trying to be a
little bit annoying them
jumpin night-night F force not really
I'm not really more that's great
and if I go back it's going to go 95
okay
[Music]
sting is Queen g5 and more fairness
plural
I can go I can go be should be three
kind of silly to say this idea
[Music]
I was a bit silly
you
okay 25 was one of the more stupid ideas
that you could come up with in this
position Oh God
you
I think my position is they need
somewhat solid but it's not great
I've with those weird maneuvers I'm not
I have not improved
yeah let's let's play chess in the
center of the board oftentimes a good
idea
we should perform it's my idea
it's a newsletter Bishop c5 was move
that ahead considered anyway and after
a5 it gets more interesting
hmm he doesn't react to it that's
interesting
now see five all of a sudden my position
is great I don't know how that happened
the widest toes to him threatening
deform and you cannot unpin this really
remarkable
I mean it's clear that you all will look
bishop before but it really is a total
disaster
mm yeah I'm just taking it
there's just not enough compensation
you
rook-a for is an interesting one
but I have deform
and this first him this first no yeah
that was it was weird
okay so let's have a look at all this
castles I think this is just not working
yeah looky one d5 take take 93 and I
think it's just I mean it's better to
have the night yeah that looks better
it seems queen c6 is playable but yeah
it it looks wrong so these six yes okay
no it takes I think this is all kind of
normal a night before I missed the same
I missed the same thing in the game
before in the in the earlier game that
is an interesting move yeah there's
stuff like that yeah okay I mean this is
okay but it's not as convincing so I was
I was happy basically with what I did
up to a point yeah this this was okay I
believe and now I should probably not do
this night h5 stuff or at least play
Knight a for now in the the way I played
it was kind of was kind of didn't lead
to anything no and now I realized okay
let's get get this get this stuff back
into the center and I think from here he
he kind of goes astray and Albert b3
Knight f6f-5 and Bishop c5 and now
something else I think we should be to
us is really it doesn't look that bad in
another lecture what the ideas actually
have for I mean the problem is I'm
threatening Bishop before you have to do
something about that
after that it's immediately lost its
just lost
because I have the the ideas c5i it's
remarkable me know my minus two point
three this is exactly on the wrong
position so that there's no nighty to
ever and here he cannot stop the simply
and over
it's an eternal opinion yeah
remarkable how quickly that went
downhill after this one one mistake okay
guys thanks for watching